okay so these are some
um imaginations or
imaginings or mindset to help you get
the
cadence for show
and to have it have
some sense of danger and
also some sense of austerity
for the taking of the life and for the
life you took
okay um so just things that will help
if you think about these things it'll
fix your body
okay um you don't want to be
a big target you're in a big knife fight
so you want to be small you want to be
big
because that is more vulnerable you a
bigger target
in a knife fight is not a good thing
okay
so uh have a sense of
be a small target as possible my hands
are here
not here like this okay when i grab the
sword i don't grab the sword all big
i grab it from the sense of smallness
you see
i don't want limbs sticking out
the success of the nuke scan of the
drawing cut
is not derived from the speed of my cut
but how long it takes
the opponent to recognize
that an attack has started so what i'm
doing is i'm not trying to make
me go faster i'm trying to
push back their response
so in a sense they're starting later
so it's more about disguising it so if
you look
at how would i stand up it would be
like this
i'm going to stand down and do nothing
so i want to try to
mimic as much of that
in the cut so
i have to decorum requires i hold the
sword
right so this hand is the first
thing that is giving a cue that
something different is happening
so that's going to be obvious
uh so this hand goes this way
you see and this
is more obvious than this so the more
movement i add
the more telegraphing i'm doing the more
i'm moving their response sooner
okay also if i do things independently
that's easy for us to recognize but if i
uh move all these things together so
they move together they move together
not
one two right and they move together
with
with my body so my body is moving you
see
and i try to hide it as long as possible
hide it as long as possible same thing
goes with my tension
that's all telegraphing you're gonna see
it okay
so your mind is actually like chill
chill chill relax because you're trying
to hide the movement
okay so i'm actually physically skinny
but my mind is i'll hide the movement
hide the movement
don't freak out and so when i do knit
scare
it's just very
okay by the time they figure out what's
happening the sword should probably be
somewhere around here
and the cut comes out
that's my goal number one
okay now you did your cut
don't be in a hurry right
if you were hurt in a hurry this guy
must have been
still a threat so you would jump
you would get out if the guy is still a
threat
so my move was successful
okay and now i have somebody bleeding
out
so same sense of danger same sense of
austerity
don't be don't rush in don't move
quickly okay so i'm here
just move
posture again observe
and prepare yourself for
the killing okay uh you don't take these
strikes out of
whack we're not berserkers okay
so as i coming around
take a breath
when i do the kitty i go through the
target
by extending the cut past your normal
showmanship so here's
showman tsuburi and i'm just going to
extend the
cut the sword
would stop here normally but i keep the
cut going
and the tip drops do you see the tip's
not dropping
because i point my wrist down there's no
strength in that kind
so just bring the
sword closer to your body and you'll get
it
okay if i come back up this width away
from my body
it would be parallel with that okay so
don't
flick it down and this wouldn't do the
job
finish the cut more okay
then same thing have some austerity here
on the mercy blow you just did there's
no rush
and you won't find it easy to get this
thing out
so pry do you see how i'm grounding
get up choke up on the grip
push it through
online don't take their blood and throw
it out
observe
reposition
release all the tension release it all
find your breath observe again
you don't need to rest on the ground
just
kiss the ground
scenario hasn't reset
okay